Bonjour!
Pour notre dernière gente dame badass de
l'été, j'ai choisi de vous parler d'une
personne qui n'est pas restée célèbre pour
sa haute naissance mais pour son œuvre scientifique
et artistique.
Anna Maria Sibylla Merian, qu'on va tout de
suite appeler Anna Maria pour aller plus vite,
est née à Francfort en 1647.
Son père meurt lorsqu'elle a trois ans, mais
elle apprend la peinture, le dessin et la
gravure auprès de son beau-père, Jakob Marell,
dès son enfance.
Très jeune aussi, elle s'intéresse aux insectes
et en capture pour les dessiner:
«Je me suis dans ma jeunesse employée
à la recherche des insectes.
J'ai d'abord commencé avec les vers à soie
dans ma ville natale de Francfort-sur-le-Main.
J'ai ensuite établi que, à partir des autres
chenilles, se développaient beaucoup de beaux
papillons de nuit ou papillons de jour, comme
à partir des vers à soie.
Cela m'entraîna à recueillir toutes les
chenilles que je pouvais trouver pour observer
leur transformation.»
A 18 ans, elle épouse le peintre Johann Andreas
Graff et ils partent s'installer à Nuremberg
avec leur fille.
A partir de là Anna Maria s'intéresse plus
spécifiquement aux papillons et à leur cycle
de vie: à l'époque, on n'avait pas encore
trop compris le principe de la chenille, la
chrysalide puis le papillon.
On croyait encore parfois au principe de «génération
spontanée», une idée d'Arisote qui expliquait
que certaines espèces vivantes apparaîtraient
comme par magie (ou sorcellerie) d'un objet
inanimé comme de la boue, des moisissures...
Anna Maria se demande toutefois comment le
papillon apparaît à partir de la chenille
et dessinne des croquis de chrysalides, des
plantes dont les chenilles se nourrissent,
des parasites qu'on trouve dans les cocons...
A 28 ans, elle fait paraître le Nouveau livre
de fleurs, un livre de croquis.
Son deuxième livre s'appelle La chenille,
merveilleuse transformation et étrange nourriture
florale, dans lequel elle présente les stades
de développement des différentes espèces
de papillons avec les plantes dont ils se
nourrissent.
Dans ses travaux, elle cherche aussi à trouver
une espèce qui pourrait remplacer le ver
à soie qu'on n'arrive pas à faire vivre
en Europe.
Elle se sépare de son mari en 1685 et divorce
en 1690.
A partir de là elle vit à Amsterdam, et
continue ses études et ses collections d'insectes,
de coquillages et de coraux tout en élevant
ses deux filles.
Elle gagne sa vie en réalisant des illustrations
pour des livres d'autres auteurs, et décide
en 1699, à 52 ans, de partir pour le Suriname
avec l'une de ses filles pour y trouver des
papillons et étudier la faune et la flore.
Les voyages à caractère scientifique sont
rares à son époque, Elle reçoit une bourse
d'étude de la ville d'Amsterdam, vend une
partie de ses collections et lance une souscription
(un crowdfunding) sur le livre qu'elle publiera
après son voyage.
Un gros aspects négatifs de son voyage au
Suriname: elle travaille surtout depuis
son jardin à Paramaribo et emploie des esclaves
qui l'aident dans ses excursions et son travail.
Et ne mentionne pas leurs noms dans ses travaux.
En 1701, elle est obligée de rentrer aux
Pays-Bas parce qu'elle a attrapé le paludisme
pendant son voyage, mais avec assez de croquis
et d'insectes pour publier son Metamorphosis
insectorium Surinamensium.
C'est sa plus grosse œuvre, même si elle
ne se vend pas très bien et elle est obligée
de vendre ses peintures et d'en donner des
cours pour vivre même si elle avait par ailleurs
déjà une bonne réputation en tant que naturaliste
et artiste.
Elle meurt finalement en 1717, à 70 ans.
Son livre est réédité plusieurs fois au
cours du XVIIIe siècle, et montre l'apport
d'Anna Maria dans le domaine du naturalisme:
à son époque peu de personnes s'intéressaient
aux papillons, parce qu'à cause de la théorie
de la génération spontanée dont je parlais
plus tôt ils avaient mauvaise réputation,
on les appelait les «bêtes du diable».
Le seul point négatif qui fait que d'autres
naturalistes de l'époque l'évitent, c'est
qu'elle écrit en allemand alors que la langue
officielle des sciences est encore le latin
à l'époque.
Alors pourquoi figure-t-elle parmi les gentes
dames badass? Parce que c'est une femme
naturaliste, ce qui était déjà rare pour
l'époque, et parce que c'est la première
femme à avoir effectué un voyage pour la
science.
Même au XIXe, on trouve des femmes qui voyageaient
sous les tropiques mais c'était le plus souvent
pour suivre leur mari; or, son mari, elle
l'avait quitté depuis longtemps au moment
du voyage.
A l'époque quelques scientifiques, comme
Johann Friedrich Blumenbach, considéraient
même qu'il était dangereux pour les femmes
de voyager sous ces latitudes car cela risquait
de déclencher leurs menstruations et de les
tuer.
Bloody hell!
Puisque ceci était le dernier
épisode de l'été, je vous souhaite une
bonne rentrée (haha) et on se retrouve très
bientôt pour du Chroniques de Prof.
Aurevoir.